hi I'm Scott Schneider hey my name is
Greg Horowitz hi this is Neil Adams
Athens Geoff Johns hi this Greg Capullo
I'm here at New York City comic-con 2012
this is Batman 101 join in Batman to me
has always been the dark night the the
darkest gloomiest
most gothic of all of of all DC's
characters I mean you're growing up you
just love Batman just mainly probably
because of his look Batman is Sherlock
Holmes who could compete in the Olympics
and probably win most of the events and
and he's someone who's unafraid to go up
against the supernatural to peek into
the dark corners to find everything and
the flip side and the fuel for that for
me is it goes back to a dark alley when
he was when he was once a scared kid and
the family goes out to see a movie one
night and they're confronted by a
criminal outside after the film and
Bruce's parents are shot dead and Bruce
is obviously devastated by this and
years later Bruce becomes batmanning
spent all this all these years training
and making himself the perfect weapon to
enact justice
most of us uh you know don't like when
bad things happen to good people happen
to us or whatever and we all kind of
like would love to go and meet out
justice because you know God bless law
enforcement and everything like that
they don't always get it done right and
Batman gets it done and it's not revenge
that's a very important distinctions
that Batman is not about revenge because
he's not out there to catch the killer
his parents he's out there to prevent
that from happening to anybody else he's
he's one of the few superheroes who's
really not afraid to walk that knife
edge between sanity and insanity but
that really interesting mix of yeah
heroism and sort of completely twisted
self-destructive impulses is what's
endlessly fascinating to me because it
also makes him who wrote that he's
flawed in that way I think Batman has
been such a perennial favorite and so
popular through the years
because in some ways he represents the
best possible version of what a human
can be if it's discipline if there's
hard work if there's total physical
dedication and determination he
represents almost the peak that you can
get to if you put everything aside but
he's not magical so he is the antithesis
of superman' he is the other end of the
spectrum he is a superhero without
superpowers
you know Batman's parents can be shot
today or 100 years ago his character
still works because all of us can relate
to that pain but there's also the
fantasy of these amazing gadgets in the
car and hey there's something just
wonderfully inspiring as a kid to seeing
the coolest car in the world missiles
and all the different sort of toys and
gadgets that he has but at the end of
the day I really think what keeps him
relevant and what makes him the most
popular hero in the world if he is is
that humanity is that sense of any of us
could be Batman in our version in a way
with a sort of determination and forces
will get Bruce Epps Batman's greatest
flaw is his emotional complexity he's
put he put he put walls up around
himself and in some ways I think that
the the manner is almost a metaphor for
him like there's floors that the guests
can go to there's rooms that people can
visit but there's there's a whole hidden
area beneath that no one's allowed to
touch you can't really name a long-term
romantic interest Batman Beyond really
captain and we're dealing with that in
Joker in a lot of ways the way he
emotionally closes people off to protect
them from his mission and I think
sometimes he's right to do that and
sometimes he's wrong but it's always his
reaction I think it's a desire to not be
human he didn't want to be human he
didn't want to feel pain he didn't want
to feel loss and loneliness and so he
built up this armor and armor is
wonderful in that it protects you it
insulates you but it also reduces your
flexibility that to me is one of the
things that's
also again heroic and interestingly
complicated about my favorite Batman
villain I have to say is the Riddler Oh
a joker like hands-down
it's easy I'm supposed to at this point
say Joker and it probably is the Joker
well my favorite Batman villain is Ra's
al Ghul it seemed as though Batman
didn't have a Moriarty so Danny and I
and Julie created a Moriarity turned out
to be Ra's al Ghul you know my first
project for DC I wrote the penguin I'm a
knight and and the miniseries pain and
Prejudice and I think why started with
the penguin and why the penguin always
has a special place in my heart is
because he's the only one out of rogues
gallery who is sane this whole roll
gallery is just littered with awesome
villains love Joker obviously loved to
face being mr. freeze all those other
characters are great but there's
something about the Riddler that he
challenges Batman's mind
you don't really when you say Riddler
you don't think of these physical fights
between Batman in the Riddler you think
of these puzzles at Batman's how to
solve and I really love that as a
villain it's very unique if I was going
to recommend one Batman story to anybody
that the Batman The Dark Knight Returns
yeah Dark Knight Returns man Frank
Miller really wowed me probably pick up
year one before I pick that up because
it's a wonderful introduction to
Batman's origin I think those two
stories really they start at the
beginning and the end of Batman so
they're perfect starts to give it
anybody who's interested in that The
Killing Joke is probably my third
favorite for me it's always gonna be the
Killing Joke
there will never be a better masked
vigilante I think in fiction because
Batman is v1 and I don't think any other
character in fiction has had more
stories told about them than that so
Batman to me is the epitome of justice
and human perfection and what you can
strive to do if you put your mind and
soul into how's that I mean either
killed the Joker long ago so I mean I
think Batman which is let loose you'll
feel great and be done with it and
nobody else will get hurt by the Joker's